I believe we are set up with a journey
for you after a brilliant Victory
Journey for a nice bounce back Victory
yesterday difficult game against tatev
but you did bounce back like Champions
do how do you feel right now
um I mean I feel pretty good I was just
really disappointed by the way I played
yesterday
um I felt like I didn't even really get
a game because I probably did the worst
prop imaginable for that game and then I
just kind of wasted my time beginning
because I just couldn't move
um for some reason so I just like
sitting there and ran out of time and it
just like blundered and moved 20. so it
was just a horrible games and I just
wanted to make like play quicker today
and just make some good moves how do you
psychologically bounce back from that
what did you tell yourself
um
probably I didn't think about it too
much I was just like
I think this kind of validated me into
thinking oh if you sit there and think
you're not necessarily going to play a
good move because like what happened was
just so bad like today I was just like
let's just move you know
um like I have
I have an idea what to do like just just
make the move let's go through the game
today and point us to the critical
moments of the game
or would you say you uh let's say took
the initiative in your hands um I mean
so I thought this was all pretty normal
I probably didn't play this as
accurately as I wanted to like here this
Knight D5 just lets like this Knight
takes you to Queen takes you to 96 I
thought this made sense but E5 I wasn't
I mean
um I didn't really calculate this too
much it was just you know nothing's
hanging and I think this gave me the
best practical chances because otherwise
I don't want her to get like a piece of
night um her piece on D4 and it's just
gonna be so uncomfortable for me to play
so what if she takes you take back
Bishop takes doesn't work because the
bishop takes C4 Bishop C5 is really nice
because like no matter what it's just um
this bishop this dark circuit is too
important yeah and so if you ever lose
it it's just a lot of trouble for Block
absolutely and she played the move B5
Rook to D1
and at this point it was just feeling
like you're getting a free attack
there's nothing happening on the queen
side she's very far from opening it and
you're just uh destroying her on the
king side did you felt the same way yeah
um I think 94 here she might have missed
um after Bishop takes e4s he takes Queen
takes E4
um D takes if I think she missed like
either after this D takes C5 that takes
C5 the bishop Zane or maybe I don't know
maybe
um you can't take on E5 directly so do
you want take take yeah Bishop hanging
on G4 and also I think it just kind of
works out for me because you really want
to get E6 to work at some point well not
here before Bishop G4 but I have Queen
A7 and it's really nice because then
there's like Rook V7 and I have six
though at one point like here um take
take E6 just like doesn't work Queen
takes A7 and then okay I wasn't actually
this I think this is kind of complicated
sorry to interrupt Irena crashed the
eight-time national champion did win her
game against ashrita aswara takes the
first victory in the U.S Women's
Championship
okay let's continue Queen to A7 and then
so yeah so I was letting you Rook B7
um Knight F6 and then okay here yeah and
it just doesn't quite work out because
you want to take and Bishop takes E5 but
I have D4 like just in time pretty nice
otherwise it was a little otherwise
Bishop D4 might be problematic of course
very nice nicely uh calculated she
played Bishop to G4 she was trying to
open you up on this side but at this
point
there was no turning back for her
um very nice of victory for you are you
going to do uh some homework tonight or
what's the plan oh yeah I have a big
deadline I
a few hours before midnight gotta turn
that in
um but yeah it's same thing every day
Jennifer good luck uh with your homework
and good luck in the rest of your games
do you don't turn in that